my mom started putting like a little bit
of coffee in my hot chocolate and the
first day I almost like [ __ ] my pants on
the way to school I started drinking
coffee when I was in the second grade
it's like the first thing I drink every
morning drink it all the way through the
day I'm a late coffee adopter and now I
can't stop I love it I need it every day
coffee and me is getting a little out of
control
lately in the mornings in terms like a
ratio I think would be like a 2 is the
one with sugar and natural coffees yeah
I would say I have at least one or two
cups of coffee every morning and that's
after like a caffeine pill to go to the
gym I have a committed relationship with
coffee and then click smoking a long
time ago and coffee is a great thing for
that
all right so you guys are going to be
trying to differentiate between decaf
and regular coffee are there really
people who think they can tell the
difference I bet I can tell the
difference you're sitting next to one I
don't believe in decaf coffee yeah it's
stupid why why sure I can taste the
caffeine that's for sure in pieces yes I
can taste it it's them all over all the
sugar you can taste the cafe's pretty
smooth like a standard cup of coffee I
don't know weird that it's just being
water though this tastes like nothing
oh definitely this one it's this one
yeah that's what starts okay so that's a
little harder this one it feels like
there's something missing maybe
interesting I'm gonna say the opposite
this one kind of tastes like gas station
coffee yeah this is more watery I'm
gonna I'm gonna assume that you're not
tricking us because that's just screwin
me up I'm gonna be like really
embarrassed messes up yeah you drink
like five you should know okay just cuz
I want to be controversial and because
my taste buds are all messed up I'm
gonna go this that's decaf
caffeinated decaf bet my firstborn on it
I think right is caffeinated okay I
think I'm gonna agree with you I think
this is I think this one's caffeinated
this one's deeper final answer decaf
regular this one right here this thing I
believe the opposite I think right is
decaffeinated and left is caffeinated
coffee yes got it
I nailed it I've been practicing this
for
20 years so I was right the first time
and then I got influenced Oh Danis like
coffee centers they're way off
it's pointless I don't see the use of it
unless you like the flavor like you're
absolutely genuine like the flavor and
you don't want to say oh they're both
good though I would read you're one of
you actually yeah and if you didn't tell
me the decaf was decaf I would probably
drink it and feel like I got my coffee
for the day so big supporter of decaf
and I'm embarrassed that I couldn't tell
the difference ABDC always be drinking
coffee
[Music]
you